[Music]
Jenna Dewan gets candid about life after
ending her nine-year marriage to
Channing Tatum he doesn't mess her up in
a new interview with Harper's Bazaar the
37 year old mom opens up about how the
exes are finding a new normal
quote we're just getting used to it
we're in a very positive energy together
trying to be the best parents to ever
leave as for learning to step into the
spotlight on her own
the dancing beauty explains I feel a
sense of joy and freedom and excitement
truly about a new chapter in my life I
think it's just gonna be bigger and
better and more expansive
on Tuesday Jena will reunite with
Jennifer Lopez and their fellow world of
dance judges for the season 2 premiere
with herself and she couldn't help but
gush about her mentor to the mag she's
just a really beautiful empowered woman
who's also a great mother as for being a
mom herself Jenna calls four-year-old
Everly her little mirror and says she
inspires me to get clearer and more
willful in my own life
[Music]
[Applause]